does a deal make sense I mean if Ford
were to announces buying PG&E because it
wants to cover everything from the
creation of energy or ExxonMobil maybe I
mean this is a very strange thing yes
there's a commonality in terms of the
Clean Energy notion I suppose and yes
maybe more importantly Elon Musk is
using one company to bail out an
investment in another company that's
fallen substantially the last year but
just a look at the pure numbers shows
how crazy this deal is okay if you look
at how much cash Tesla has on hand and
then throw in the debt you've got a
company that really you know can't
afford solar city I mean Tesla's got one
point four billion dollars in cash
they've got 3.2 billion people to
billion dollars in debt right so you
look at the casual go dead solar city
it's 5.8 billion dollars in enterprise
value if you if you use if you look at
the total value of the company by
including the debt so Tesla doesn't look
Tesla's got a billion foreign in cash
and it has to build more factories to
build an amount of cars they've
announced now they're gonna somehow
raise more money or to acquire a company
it's in a very different business and it
is installing rooftop solar is a very
different business than manufacturing
cars to try to do both at once is is a
very disparate now Tesla isn't just
manufacturing cars anymore they're
making batteries and on-call musk said
this is something that we've been
debating and thinking about for years as
in buying Solar City and the timing
seemed right at this point because Tesla
is ramping up its activity with power
wall and the power pack essentially with
power storage when you think about it
that way it doesn't make more sense
I mean it's unclear what kind of
business power wall is going to have
right I mean they've got a great dreams
for power wall but most people have no
use for power wall the principal use of
the factories coming out of the
Panasonic Tesla plant in Nevada are
going to be batteries for Tesla cars so
the notion that they're in this power
supply business is is ambitious but it's
a car maker this value as a car maker if
you live always happen the stock of
Tesla after-hours shares are plummeting
down more than 11 percent in after-hours
trading I think a lot of tests are
shareholders gonna say wait a minute
you're taking this business we think has
great potential of making cars yes they
make them they lose money in every car
but maybe someday they can be profitable
that stock is tanking right now
so spiking on this news now Elon has
said he's going to abstain from this
vote but let's talk about his
involvement in both of these companies
and what this means well I mean he's put
the board together in both companies the
board is the CEO of Solar City but more
to the point the Board of Directors in
both companies are have worked with Elon
and supported Elon and everything that
he's done thus far so the notion that
that these companies can be independent
I think as you know it's it's good at
him to recuse himself he absolutely
should but I don't think we should look
at those boards and say they are
completely without influence upon each
other or or don't follow the the desires
of Elon ma so my question is why now
Tesla's supposed to be focusing on the
model 3 he said he was sleeping in the
sleeping bag at the end of the
production line what is the impetus at
this very moment for them to make this
offer
look financially both companies need a
big change Tesla does not have some some
critics say that Tesla does not have the
cash it needs in order to build the
backs extra plants you know in to
support the production goals that they
have announced the accelerator
productions goals as they have announced
this notion for example they're going to
open up factories in China which we
reported on yesterday it seems to me
like well where are they gonna get the
money for that so Tesla doesn't it's
gonna be very expensive them for to do
all the things that they've announced
they're going to do so the city's got
its own set of financial problems maybe
this is just a rearranging of all the
deck chairs and and an opportunity for
testing to a massive capital raise to
fund this and everything else is trying
to do